the latest DC superhero movie is upon us
this time introducing the world to Blue
Beetle but though he may be new to the
big screen there are plenty of
references to his long history hidden in
the margins these are the secrets we
spotted warning spoilers ahead
the first character we see in Blue
Beetle isn't Jaime Reyes or the villain
Victoria court it's Conrad karapak's
Victoria's lieutenant and bodyguard who
acts as the direct foil to Jaime it's an
interesting choice making the first face
we see be that of a supporting villain
but carapax ends up being much more
Central to the overarching themes of the
movie of course if you've read the
comics you're already well acquainted
with a character in The Blue Beetle
Comics carapax is known as the
indestructible man his mind becomes one
with a powerful robot body due to a
strange accident making him a formidable
threat to anyone he comes up against his
robot body in the comics is pretty
similar to his depiction in the movie
when his full omac suit is activated red
in color with angular shoulder plates
and a massive helmet with a y-shaped
visor though his story in the Blue
Beetle movie is quite different carapax
retains some of his comic book Essence
we see how injury after injury in the
service of Victoria led to a gradual
replacement of his body parts with
mechanical augmentations slowly he
becomes a full cyborg always the one who
who has to sacrifice for the good of
Court Industries it's a brutal Twist on
karapak's comic origin story but it
works well on the big screen
karapex and Blue Beetle is actually a
combination of two different characters
from the comic books in the past
indestructible man has been completely
separate from Buddy blank omac the
so-called one-man Army Corps the acronym
has that same meaning in the Blue Beetle
movie but it refers instead to a weapon
system an approximation of the Scarab
battle suit exoskeleton that Victoria
court is attempting to mass produce for
private policing the original omac is
actually a hero a super spy of sorts but
the name was later applied to a cyber
virus that assimilates subjects into
robotic Warriors the acronym came to
stand for Omni mind and Community the
name given to the group of enhanced
Fighters controlled by brother I in
artificial intelligence that circles the
Earth from space the omax first appeared
in 2005's omac Project number one
neither of these versions is really
represented in the film but combining
the idea of cyber assimilation with the
backstory of karapax is a nice fit
Victoria does want to create a whole
Army of soldiers which is similar to the
second Incarnation from the comics if
nothing else it's a fun nod to a deep
cut DC character buddy blank who was
created by Jack Kirby and first appeared
back in 1974.
at the beginning of Blue Beetle Jaime
has just graduated from college earning
a bachelor's degree in pre-law because
of his family's Financial circumstances
continuing his education in law school
is out of the question but we get a
small glimpse of what a different future
for Jaime might have looked like in an
early scene Jaime has a heart-to-heart
chat with his father Alberto in their
Garden Alberto points out some plants
that he planted with Nana when Jaime was
just a little kid plants that Nana later
salvages to replant at the end of Blue
Beetle they talk about the Journey of
life and the importance of family it's a
tender moment and an emotional high
point of the film's first half during
the whole scene Jaime is wearing a
Gotham law sweatshirt it seems likely
that in another reality Jaime would have
attended the school regardless going to
law school in Gotham City is a bold move
sure you'd get on the job experience
dealing with the most corrupt criminal
community in the world but is that
really worth the danger of living there
it's likely that this detail is just a
little Easter egg with no larger
narrative significance but it's cool to
picture Jaime in Gotham
Blue Beetle has become something of a
bridge film for DC the point at which we
cross over from the dceu to James Gunn's
all-new DCU it's an important film in
that sense but it's far from original in
terms of its tone fans of superhero
movies won't fail to notice that Blue
Beetle has a lot in common with the
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man films the goofy sequence of
Jaime trying to understand his powers
the evil Corporation that's creating
sci-fi weapons for the military the
scene where a hapless protagonist
stumbles into a tech Facility by
coincidence and walks out with
superpowers it all evokes an earlier era
of comic book movie there's even a
moment where Jaime's mask gets ripped
just like Peter Parker's in the original
Spider-Man during his battle with the
Green Goblin some moments also evoke
more recent superhero Fair the mildly
cyberpunk neon aesthetic of Palmyra City
and the thumping synthwave soundtrack
will surely draw comparisons to the
spider-verse films and Jaime's Cosmic
dream meeting with his dead father feels
directly inspired by black panther
fortunately Blue Beetle combines all of
these disparate elements into a hole
that's greater than the sum of its parts
you can easily see the sources of
inspiration but the movie itself feels
distinctly like its own thing you are
it's clear from the start of Blue Beetle
that Victoria cord and her company are
up to no good she's such an outlandish
cartoonish villain that she feels ripped
from the early 2000s but even with Susan
Sarandon's scenery chewing performance
the true villainy of chord Industries
isn't as front and center we get all the
pieces but you have to put them together
yourself in an early video montage that
plays in the chord Industries Lobby we
see that the company has mining
operations in Guatemala Victoria later
mentions that she chose carapax as her
primary omac subject because of his
Valance in anti-communist
counter-terrorist operations in the same
country by the end of Blue Beetle we
learned that carapax was actually
abducted as a child and forced into
military service after his home was
destroyed cord's operations in Guatemala
used the guise of Liberation to
establish a local stake and start
plundering natural resources the cord
real estate signs around the keys also
show how active the company is in
pushing out the local Latino community
in Palmyra and gentrifying the
neighborhood tripling rent on the Reyes
family with full knowledge that they
won't be able to pay it and that's
without going into all of Victoria's
microaggressions which just reiterate
that she sees the Latino Community as
something to be exploited
Blue Beetle is more show than tell when
it comes to explaining the actual powers
of the Scarab Jaime's frantic test
sequence in which he flies into outer
space cuts a bus in half and blasts two
holes in his family home demonstrates
the exosuit's capabilities pretty well
the rest of the movie shows his new
powers in combat such as his ability to
conjure weapons from his imagination
Green Lantern style various projectile
devices and Deployable Shields
whatever you can imagine
I can create
most of these abilities like the design
of the Blue Beetle suit itself are
ripped straight out of the comics blue
Beetle's look is incredibly loyal to his
Incarnation on the page and details like
his dual swords translucent Wings energy
blasters and healing Factor are all key
pieces of Jaime's comic book counterpart
because of the nature of the Scarab
Jaime is kind of a catch-all when it
comes to Powers more like Iron Man than
the more singular focus of someone like
Aquaman or the flash but the movie
incorporates all of blue Beetle's
different powers and abilities in a
cohesive way making his action scenes in
the third act super fun to watch
one of the smaller DC Easter eggs in
Blue Beetle is big belly Burger a
fictional fast food chain that pops up
regularly in the comics and in on-screen
adaptations first introduced in
Adventures of Superman in the late 1980s
the Eatery has been a staple in Man of
Steel stories ever since while also
leaking out into other areas of the DC
Universe more recently big belly Burger
has made numerous appearances in
arrowverse shows like the flash
Supergirl and legends of Tomorrow Blue
Beetle marks the fake Brand's debut in a
live-action DC movie a couple of big
belly Burger ads can be seen around
Palmyra City but its biggest part in the
story comes when Jaime first acquires
the Scarab when Jenny cord steals it
from her aunt's lab she hides the
artifact in a big belly Burger takeout
box
with real life but do not open it she
gives it to Jaime in the box so that he
can safely get it out of the cord
Industries building
Blue Beetle is a superhero with a long
and storied history Jaime Reyes may be
the latest and most well-known character
to use the name but he's actually the
third person to do so in the comics the
first Incarnation Dan Garrett with one
tea debuted for Fox Comics all the way
back in 1939. this early version gained
his powers from a special vitamin and it
wasn't until he was relaunched by
Charlton Comics as the almost
identically named Dan Garrett now with
two T's that the Scarab a magical
Egyptian artifact was introduced the
next character to use the Blue Beetle
moniker Ted cord was also introduced by
Charlton but he later became part of the
DC Mythos unlike his predecessor cord
never bonded with a Scarab instead using
various gadgets to get the job done the
Blue Beetle movie pays tribute to these
previous versions of the hero Ted cord
is hugely important as Victoria's
brother and Jenny's father and we spend
a lot of time in his batcave-esque
superhero Lair complete with his old
suits while digging through Ted's old
files Rudy uncovers the previous host of
the Scarab whose name is Dan Garrett
they even mentioned Garrett being a
professor which is his job and
relationship to Ted in his second comic
book Incarnation like his Illustrated
counterpart the film's Ted never uses
the Scarab instead creating his own
superhero devices
while not quite Batman and made fun of
in the movie for that exact reason Ted
cord was clearly an impressive inventor
his old Lair is packed with Comics
accurate Blue Beetle suit designs
energy-based weapons created using the
scarabs technology and various other
gizmos not only is this aspect of Ted's
character true to the comics but the
items themselves include numerous
references and Easter eggs in his comic
book Adventures Ted uses various energy
and Sonic weapons to fight off bad guys
these devices are represented in the
Arsenal of gear that the Reyes family
uses to free Jaime however the biggest
Easter egg among Ted's Blue Beetle gear
is the bug the giant armored flying
vehicle that Jenny and the family take
to Victoria's Island Fortress the bug is
a staple of Ted cord's Blue Beetle and
it features many familiar abilities in
the film from its impenetrable armor and
Swift flying speed to the physical
design a blue Scarab shape with six legs
and two giant yellow eyes the movie
version is a great match
Latino culture and history are important
in Blue Beetle director Angel Manuel
Soto screenwriter Gareth dunnett
alcosare and many members of the cast
have spoken in interviews about the
importance of representation and
authenticity in the project the support
he gets from his family and Community is
Jaime's true superpower and the film
also deals heavily with the Immigrant
experience given that done at alcosare
was born in Mexico it shouldn't be
surprising that Blue Beetle takes the
opportunity to reference a few Mexican
TV Classics the 1990s telenovela Maria
la del Barrio is referenced several
times with Jaime's family jokingly
comparing him to the protagonist the
original series follows a young woman
named Maria who's taken out of poverty
and brought up by a wealthy businessman
and one scene of Blue Beetle Nana can
even be seen watching the show the other
Mexican TV show referenced is the 1970s
superhero parody comedy El chapulin
Colorado the original series follows the
adventures of the eponymous hero whose
name translates to either the red
grasshopper or the Cherry Cricket given
the show's culture staying power and the
familiar idea of a colorful bug-themed
superhero it's a perfect inclusion
specifically Uncle Rudy hacks the cord
industry's security cameras replacing
their footage with claymation clips of
el chapulin Colorado the Blue Beetle
post credit scene features additional
footage
Blue Beetle evokes an older era of
action-adventure movies one where corny
lines goofy gags and snarling villains
reigned Supreme it's a movie that loves
being a movie and it includes a bunch of
references to some cinematic grades in a
nod to Back to the Future Jaime calls
Uncle Rudy Mexican Doc Brown given his
penchant for homemade gadgets Jaime's
sister Milagro refers to Victoria Court
as Cruella Kardashian referencing both
the famous reality TV family and 101
Dalmatians right before Victoria's
soldiers Infiltrate The Reyes house
Nana's tea vibrates slightly as the
helicopter approaches evoking the iconic
dinosaur stop shot from Jurassic Park
later during his climactic duel with
Jaime karapax declares boldly that there
can only be one of us this may well be a
reference to the 1986 fantasy classic
Highlander which spawned the famous line
there can be
Blue Beetle doesn't stop at classic
movie references either during his big
hallway fight scene in Victoria's Island
Fortress Jaime Spears alaki with one of
his Stinger arms and pulls him through
the air shouting get over here as he
does it seems likely that it's a Mortal
Kombat reference as the character
scorpion always says the same thing
after yanking an opponent toward him
with his own spear
[Music]
over here
though Blue Beetle spends a lot of time
developing Jaime his family and Court
Industries it spends much less time
explaining the Scarab itself we're told
that it's some kind of world-destroying
weapon that it's of alien origin and
that the sentience within it is called
kajida beyond that though no real info
is revealed if you've read the Blue
Beetle Comics then you'll know all about
the reach the alien race of violent
conquerors who created and sent the
Scarab you'll also know that kajida's
purpose was to conquer Earth in the name
of the reach if you're coming to the
film more casually you may have no idea
that the device is so Sinister though
the few Clues we do get point to this
fact as of now it's unclear how closely
the DCU Scarab will resemble its comic
book counterpart in origin and purpose
that will be a subject for the
hypothetical sequel to address however
Jaime's Cosmic dream sequence at the end
of Blue Beetle handset kajida's greater
Powers is this moment a glimpse of the
scarab's abilities will it have some
connection to the dcu's version of the
reach only time will tell
foreign
[Music]